[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after weeks of demonstrations against
police brutality
nigerian forces armed with automatic
rifles
opened fire against protesters in lagos
it happened in the city's leki district
and according to amnesty international
at least 12 people were killed the
nigerian authorities
have failed to provide official figures
on the streets of africa's largest city
young nigerians are feeling
increasingly angry with political
leaders viewed as
ineffectual and out of touch here's why
[Applause]
the campaign against sars a now
disbanded branch of nigeria's police
force
has gone global it has backing from
athletes
i would say nigerian government you guys
are ashamed to the world
we've been making some tangible efforts
to try and support your protests on the
ground
and music stars like beyonce rihanna
and burner boy this is the most
important moment
in nigeria's history if this doesn't
work
then you know it's over
sars is short for special anti-robbery
squad
it was set up in 1992 to combat
armed robberies and other violent crimes
but critics accuse it
of beatings extortion extrajudicial
killings
and other human rights abuses
there have been a number of end sars
campaigns since 2016
but the latest round of protests are
different
they were sparked by a widely circulated
video
of a sars officer allegedly shooting a
young nigerian
in delta state demonstrations have been
taking place for weeks
using the social media hashtag ensars
to rally huge crowds in response to the
demonstrations
nigeria's president muhammadu buhari
said he would dissolve the sars unit
and promised an investigation into
police violence
but many protesters don't buy it they
point out that sars has been
reformed and re-badged several times
over the last few years
and they have little faith that anything
will change
many of the protesters are young in
their teens and twenties
and they feel despondent about their
future prospects
nigeria is the african continent's
biggest oil producer
but low oil prices have battered the
economy
and the fallout from the coronavirus
pandemic has left millions
on the very edge more than a third of 15
to 34 year olds
are currently unemployed with little
chance of work
what started out as a protest against
sars
has broadened into something else a
challenge to the government's authority
its right to rule over two hundred
million people
buildings have been torched a bus depot
burned
and a tv station attacked by agitators
forcing the staff to flee started
attacking us inside the studio i had to
cut off the shoe
and we couldn't go up we can't continue
the show right now i don't even know
what to do
and while a strict curfew has been
imposed
security forces have struggled to
enforce it
the birth of this political movement has
been assisted by the fact that it is
essentially
leaderless the authorities can't arrest
the people in charge
because there aren't any but that may
also be its biggest
weakness without a proper leadership
structure
this is a movement that will be very
difficult to control in the future